roll call
who saw my first anti anxious station
and who saw that concept blow up
I was kinda surprised if I'm honest
because what started out as an inside joke
that I had with myself
ended up helping me and a whole bunch of other people
you might know that
BraveFace has been a staple of my
anti anxious station for almost two years
now and I'm so excited
because we've teamed up
and also looped in a couple of my other favourite local brands
so that you can easily curate a calming and uplifting little space
with the sole intent and purpose of making you feel fkn fabulous
you can pick and choose which products you like to add to your bundle
and whether or not you’d like the tray
and I must admit
the four words on the tray were the hardest four words I've ever written
like how difficult to encapsulate your entire ethos into one short sentence?!
But I have this theory in life
that the things that actually terrify you
are the things that you need to run towards
and for an anxious person
that's hard so
this serves as a twice daily reminder to keep showing up for yourself
and to keep doing brave things
word to the wise
don't get the brave face cool head and the calm mood face mist confused
the face mist acts like therapy and reminds me to feel calm
and all the Brave Face products are taken orally
so that you absorb those active ingredients
top it all off with a feel good smoked lavender candle
it's all limited edition and just went live right now